we're asked to arrange the following
measurements in order from smallest to
largest and we have the measurements and
they're different units this is in deca
meters then we have meters and we have
millimeters then we have centimeters so
the way i would tackle this is i would
try to convert them all to the same
units maybe meters and then compare them
all in terms of meters so let's do that
so this is just a screenshot of that
exact same screen we just saw there and
so let's just convert each of these into
meters so the first one we have right
over here is one
one
deca-meter so we have to remind
ourselves what deca even means well deca
deca is equal to 10 meters and actually
let me add more of these just so that we
know all of the different prefixes we
could have so you have deca
you have hecto which would be 100 you
have kilo
which would be 1000
and then of course you just have meters
and you'd have no prefix there that
would just be equal one if you have no
prefix in front of the meters and then
if you have a tenth of a meter that is
decimeter so this is one tenth then you
have centi
which is one hundredth
and then you have milli
which is equal to
one thousandth so let's use this
information right over here to figure
out how many meters each of these are
so one decameter
one
deca-meter
decameter we just saw deca means 10
that's one
1 times 10 meters so this is going to be
equal to 10
10 meters so this right over here is 10
meters this is already written in meters
this is 13 meters
then we have 15 000 millimeters so it's
millimeters and but milli means one
thousandth so it's fifteen thousand
times one
thousandth
of a meter
so each millimeter is one thousandth of
a meter this is you could view this
instead of writing a milli here i wrote
one thousandth so fifteen thousand times
one
that's just going to give me 15. so this
is going to be 15
meters so this is 15
meters another way i've realized of
thinking about it is look a thousand
millimeters is equal to a meter so let's
divide this into groups of a thousand
well this is literally 15 groups of a
thousand this is 15 groups of a thousand
millimeters so that's going to be 15
meters
and then finally we have 1900
centimeters
so 1900
1900 instead of writing centi i'm going
to write 100th
100th
of a meter well 1900 times 1 over 100 is
19. so this is equal to 19
19 meters another way of thinking about
it is this is 19 groups of 100
centimeters and 100 centimeters is equal
to a meter this is 19
this is 19 meters right over here so
let's go back to our
to the actual problem so let's remind
ourselves this right over here this is
10 meters
this is 10 meters this is
meters so 10 13
this right over here was 15 meters and
this right over here was
19 meters so actually the order that
they already gave it to us in we could
obviously swap things around if we
wanted to but the order that they
already gave it to was the was the order
from smallest to largest this is 10
meters 13 meters
15 meters and 19 meters